To live on Earth is to live as part
of a network:
a giant web where almost every creature
depends on others for survival.
These networks are so complex that it's
difficult to predict how resilient
they might be to changing conditions.
Let's take an ecosystem in Australia,
where certain plants
have a symbiotic relationship with various ants.
The ants act as bodyguards
protecting the plants
who in return provide food and shelter for the ants.
But it's not like every kind of plant
has its own species of ant;
that would be much too easy.
In fact, each ant can visit
a variety of plants
and each plant benefits from the protection
of a number of different
kinds of ant.
You can see how quickly a network
becomes very complicated.
Let's take all the plants in the
ecosystem and draw lines
between any two species that share the same ants.
This ecosystem can be represented
by a network.
The plants are the nodes and the
connecting lines are the ants.
Two plants are linked if they share
at least one ant species.
If they share more than one,
the link is even stronger.
By helping the ants, these plants are also
indirectly helping each other.
The success of one plant
might lead to more ants
which could benefit another plant.
Having lots of connections also
means the network can adapt to change.
For example, along the bottom is a list
of all the ant species in the system.
If one of these ants disappears
the network can compensate.
It's resilient...
...up to a point.
As we remove ant species
at random, one by one,
the connections in the network grow
weaker and start to disappear.
As we go along, as well as losing
whole plant species
the abundance of remaining
species gradually decreases as well.
There comes a key point
for every network
where the population of the
remaining species suddenly crashes.
The network can no longer
compensate for further changes.
Where this point comes
represents the network's resilience.
This resilience is usually thought to be
completely unpredictable
as it varies so much between
different networks
but researchers have developed
a new tool to try and simplify things.
They started with complex,
multi-dimensional networks,
all with different properties.
The clever part is
then using various mathematical techniques
to transform all these
networks into a standard model
in which the crash is always in the same place.
This means that the resilience of the
original networks is now predictable.
This can be useful in predicting how
ecosystems might react to environmental changes.
Climate change, for example, can
affect all species in a network
and their relationships,
weakening the strength
of all the connections.
This can make the resilience of a
network so low
that it might only take the removal
of a handful of species
to bring about complete collapse.
This is particularly worrying for
already fragile ecosystems
in which a tiny change could cause the extinction
of a whole host of plants and animals.
That's why it's important to have tools
to predict and prevent
these catastrophic network failures,
like the disappearance
of honey bees
or unexpected collapses in
commercial fisheries.
And these models don't just
apply to ecological systems.
The same tools can be used
to examine networks of people
from social networks to the
spread of epidemics,
banking networks in a financial crisis
and even networks of air traffic
in which a single problem
could cause huge delays.
Models of all these things
are often available already,
based on specific real-world data,
but these new mathematical tools can be
applied generally to a whole range of
different systems.
They should allow us to predict how any
network will respond to change
and could even suggest specific strategies
for preventing catastrophic
damage.
Whether its plants, planes or people
we may be a little closer to
understanding
the giant, complex networks of our planet.